at least six people have died after
their boat capsized while trying to
reach the UK from France 49 others were
rescued local officials say dozens of
boats carrying migrants were trying to
cross the channel from France French
prosecutors are investigating
despite the dangers hundreds of people
are waiting to make the journey from
France authorities say they are
scattered in makeshift camps along the
northern coast of the country well this
Afghan migrant explains why he's willing
to take the risk
if our family knows they will never love
us and we also don't want to take that
message but we have a planes future yeah
we we planned we have we want to learn
so that's very yeah we accept that risk
to go there
my dream is to learn because
we know English and we like that to
learn in their universities
our College yeah so that's our plan and
this is the only reason we want to go
there
focus on okay Asylum Seekers according
to the UK government since 2018 more
than a hundred thousand migrants crossed
the channel in small boats this year
alone the figure stands at sixteen
thousand migrants British authorities
say almost 800 migrants crossed the
channel in a single day this week in
mid-july British lawmakers passed the
illegal migration bill that will see
migrants deemed to have arrived in the
UK illegally deported to Rwanda that's a
policy that could face lengthy legal
challenges earlier this week the UK
started housing Asylum Seekers on a
barge of England's South Coast but all
39 migrants were removed after bacteria
which can cause pneumonia was found in
the onboard water system
well migrant deaths in the government's
policy towards Asylum Seekers have
dominated British newspaper headlines
left-leaning papers like the mirror and
observer have focused on the governing
conservatives treatment of migrants
while right-leaning tabloids like the
sun and the express say people
trafficking gangs are to blame for the
crisis and call for the boats to be
stopped
well let's get more on this now we are
joined by fisa Qureshi she is CEO at
migrants rights Network and she's
joining us from working in the United
Kingdom thank you very much for your
time the UK has some nationality
specific routes that displaced people to
enter the country from places such as
Ukraine Hong Kong and Afghanistan and I
believe that six migrants or Asylum
Seekers who lost their lives were from
Afghanistan why is that
um I mean I think uh what we have is a
real welcome a positive uh schemes for
certain nationalities in certain areas
um and there is nothing for many other
nationalities so when you look at the
Sudanese conflict there has been no
um effort by our government to actually
create this scheme like the Ukrainian
want to allow people to be reunited with
their families who are already here
um or to be allowed to leave that
conflict area they've been kind of left
of their own devices sadly and so then
we ask again like who is welcome to the
UK and who is actually welcome for
Refugee protection
um it seems to be a very select few are
giving that what being given that
protection but it is my understanding
that again that the six people who lost
their lives were from Afghanistan and
like I just said the UK has a pathway
for Afghans doesn't it so why is it that
some still feel or many rather still
feel that they need to risk their lives
and catch boats and try to enter the UK
illegally
well those pathways are very restrictive
I think the pathway that does exist for
Afghan Nationals has been I think like
used by and offered to kind of a handful
of people
um so you can't expect people to sit and
wait to to do to and until the
government decides that it's going to
allow you into the country
um there are many people who are
non-afghan Nationals who are also facing
persecution and need protection and they
don't have Pathways either for
themselves
um and I think the problem is is also
um you know again there is a desperation
people think their only options will be
to get into that boat sadly and because
they don't trust some of the skiing well
the Afghan scheme which really doesn't
work in in practice okay so what do you
think the UK government needs to do then
to stop migrants to stop Asylum Seekers
from taking these very dangerous
Journeys to arrive in Britain
I mean I think what we would say is do
something similar to the Ukrainian and
the Hong Kong is scheme actually both
those schemes have worked really well
you don't hear of um Ukrainian Smugglers
smuggling groups or uh others um and so
but what we would say is really speak to
the refugees and those who have to take
these routes or or feel that they're
forced to take these routes as to what
those safe routes would look like but
there has to be a better way than what
they're doing now and offer those uh
those schemes but offer them up beyond
their nationalities but for anyone who
really needs them but do you think that
this conservative government is likely
to do that prime minister Rishi soon
access the government's first duty is to
stop illegal arrivals
yeah unfortunately we don't think they
will
um they have just rampened the rhetoric
on the small boats and and The Crossings
and you can see that with the way that
they brought in the nationality of
orders act and then and then the real
random plan came out very quickly and
now the illegal migration act which is
you know it has been passed uh also what
we really need is
um for kind of civil society and the
public to really step up the pressure on
the government and say this should not
be done in our name and we don't want to
be part of a country which prevents
people from getting protection and
prevents them from getting to safety and
is kind of forcing them into these boats
because that's the only options they
have but what do you say to those in the
United Kingdom and elsewhere who say
that they just cannot accept everyone
who wants to enter the country
I don't think everyone wants to come to
the UK I think that's that's a misnomer
but those who are coming they're coming
because they have Family Ties we do you
know forget about the legacies of
colonialism and imperialism and the fact
that these people are feeling conflicts
usually that have had some kind of input
from the UK sadly
um when we were talking about
Afghanistan
um Iraq
um and so I think it is about our duty
as a as a country in the global North to
offer people sanctuary and protection
when they come to our doorstep that is
fiza Qureshi of the migrants rights
Network joining us live from working in
the United Kingdom thank you very much
for your time
thank you